everyone felt the hard work it's hard
work you know working at a startup
trying to build a massive company for a
massive need
like what i'd like to say is that when
we came into api security um
we were already like we had to move
really really fast if we wanted to be
relevant to that problem because that
that problem was going to explode
soon and so i told the team from day one
like hey we don't have a choice like we
could choose another market and then our
work would be easier um
but we can do it now like api security
is it is really ready for us at this
moment in time let's go for it we're
gonna bust our ass but we're gonna be in
really fast you know unicorn success
anything that comes with it and this is
really what we did it
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homework ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with ctec
[Applause]
welcome to 20 minute leaders today i'm
with shai levy co-founder and cto of no
name security
shai was born in ramadan and from a very
young age he learned to adapt to
challenging life situations he paved the
way for the 8200 after studying physics
and computers in high school and hurried
to finish his matriculation in physics
in 10th grade
from the cesifian classifications to the
specific section to which he was
admitted in the army which lasted seven
months he no longer recalled
there he met oz and even then they had
signed together on a project that won
them a source of life award after they
managed to convince their commander to
promote a project that initially
encountered opposition and gained
recognition for thinking outside the box
after his military service he moved
between startups and large companies
when his last job was at facebook about
two years ago he took part in the
establishment of no name security that
provides cyber solutions for apis
[Music]
shy levy welcome to 20 minute leaders
thank you for joining me from tel aviv
how are you today
pretty good pretty good how are you i'm
i'm doing better having this episode now
no name security is
you know is a name that pretty much
every person in the tech scene
in israel and then probably much much
beyond israel knows and understands
you're working on on a problem that
really surfaced in the last i think 10
15 years pretty dramatically and you
know looking at security looking at
at apis looking at the way that security
needs to to be adapted to this new era
of collaborations and integrations both
internally within organizations and
outside and and outside of the
organizations and with an amazing
company that i think you have about 300
employees if i'm not mistaken and
probably already not updated and
obviously with a remarkable unicorn
status which which really is only
interesting to say that you're doing
something very interesting
and so i'm excited to unpack that in the
next 20 minutes and hear a little bit
about your perspective
and and shy before we even get to no
name i want to understand you a little
bit better because you have a really
interesting journey also within your
army service and the formation of of no
name so tell me a little bit about that
sure oh
do you want me to start in
or you want me to start uh before like
where do you want us to start
i want you to take me back as early as
is meaningful for you about the about
how you got to no name security
um yeah i think united 200 is a good a
good place to start um
that's essentially where i started my
professional career um
which is kind of interesting right
because we started our professional
career in the army but yeah oh
so yeah i served in union 8200 um
i've searched four years various cyber
security rules
um
you know i've did i've done initially i
did a course as part of my training so
you start by doing a programming course
and then you get into the actual unit
how long
yeah various cyber security roles from
research to development to
you know being on the offensive side
being on the defensive side pretty
interesting stuff
this is also where i met us obviously so
that's another important milestone uh we
both served in the same department uh we
had an overlap of about two years or us
was uh released two years before me uh
but we did have an overlap um after my
army service
um i had quite an interesting journey uh
i've
lived in berlin for roughly six months
uh
yeah
i met my wife there actually i met my
wife while still being in the army
service um so after i was released i i
kind of moved there
so i was in berlin for roughly six
months then i traveled the world a bit
so i traveled south america and only
then i came back to israel that was
already 216 i guess and that's when i
started kind of you know getting into
the industry um which initially was the
antique world so i came into the antique
world um
various different worlds from startups
to larger companies how long
yeah you know names you would know
probably iron source is a thing you
would know so i worked for iron source
[Music]
the last position before no name was
facebook you could say this is also an
tech it's not exactly it but i also
watch for facebook um
yeah and then and then no name
now when when you're looking back at
your army service with os and i know
that you've gotten to work on some very
meaningful projects winning the the
source of life uh
prize
that that experience working with us
back then what what was that what was
what are you thinking already about you
know startups and what you're going to
do later on in the industry was was
there any room for that thought or were
you you know really heads down in your
work and and only later on it was like
oh yeah there's this guy that i worked
with that i might want to work with
again i've always always had
something on my own that i'm working on
um at any point in in my life with any
job that i had i always had something
that i'm working on as part of it um
like aside from my main job so i also
had it during my army service um i
always knew that it would come to the
point where
i'll build like i'll build my own
company it would i knew it
i basically just knew it uh
oz was a great private partner to do it
with uh i think we both kind of felt
that we have similar thinking and we
both knew that we want to build
something together um
2020 when we started was really the
ideal time for us to start because
i left facebook basically and oz was
leaving his role and so you know we came
together
incredible and so you're coming together
and and after you know a lot of really
interesting experiences that obvi that
it it really sounds like they they
played a big role into the formation of
no name and and we we don't have enough
time to get into that now but but it is
something that fascinates me this idea
of how your previous experiences are at
the end shaping in ways we understand or
don't understand you know what we do
today
what is sort of your understanding about
the market
as you're looking at security cyber
security and apis well
what so the the vc that we started
working with is cyber starts up giving
uh so they have this process called the
sunrise where it doesn't matter which
idea you come in through the door with
you're gonna fly and meet with cecil
network off that venture capital and
talk to them about the problem see
whether the problem that you had in mind
is actually the problem that they think
is important to solve at this moment in
time and so actually we did have a
certain idea around this world of apis
but we weren't settled yet we weren't we
didn't know yet how does the solution
how is the solution going to look like
what exactly is the pain point so we
flew it open
we met with dozens of csos and we came
back with the conclusion that
api security is a big problem the
current solutions that were available in
the market does not answer the need
and that they're willing like the
customers are actually willing to pay in
order to solve that big pain that they
have
and so that was really important uh
to step in our journey right this this
is what hell this what this is what
helps
help noting to shape its solution
uh because without it you know we might
have just been shooting in the dark
right i mean at the end you know there's
the whole ideation process and then you
have different organizations and
obviously gillies is amazing and
cyberstars is amazing
you re wha what is the the understanding
that you reach after these meetings with
the csos what do you really understand
about about the world of apis you know
more more tangibly about you know how
can we actually go about and sure and
provide something that is good for these
shoes so but what we understood is that
the csos are dealing with fragmented
network which leads to the fact that
they don't know where their apis are and
they're dealing with varying fast
development velocity much faster than
the security velocity which leads to the
fact that they don't know what those
fbi's are doing so they don't know where
they are they don't know what they're
doing and they can even tell you that
they're they're important they know that
they are important they know that
they're dealing with critical pipelines
the combination of all three of those
immediately translate to the fact that
this is going to be a major attack
vector going to be very profitable for
cyber security attackers to to abuse
that and so we came down to that
conclusion that we got to help them
understand where they are we're gonna
help them understand what they're doing
and we help gotta help them stop actual
attackers from being able to
abuse their avians so that's kind of the
final conclusion that we can
came up
with
no it sounds to me that you that you're
entering this and if you're not really
you're you're not looking now to at this
point you're not looking to validate the
problem you you are can you have a
conviction that there's this deep
problem
and you pretty much know that as long as
you really execute well on it it'll work
right i mean people will will buy it
this is something that is so critical
that now it comes down to your execution
right and i have to say no when you do
go around and meet with customers hello
but it's actually a feedback that we got
pretty early on from gilly the most
important skill that you need to have is
listen you gotta listen and you have to
like it's sometimes really subtle it's
not like they'll come out and tell you
api security is my biggest problem it's
not going to be like that you really
have to figure it out
from the words they're saying and how
they're saying it is it actually a big
problem are they willing to pay for it
is it really a big pain that they have
and at this moment in time when we came
back we were convicted that yes this is
a major problem yes they will be willing
to pay for it even if some of them
weren't at this moment in time we knew
that they're gonna get there because
there was enough traction there was
enough
like we felt like this is it like that's
the right idea and we went for it
right
i love it i think you're touching on an
interesting point here you know i think
that you know i'm imagining as a founder
you have this idea that you want to go
and validate and all you're really
looking for is to finally hear somebody
say
this is the reason why i don't sleep at
night right you're just waiting for that
spark because that gives you a
legitimacy for stopping this crazy
process and continuing to the actual
execution which is you know what we also
live for right and so i i love that
intentionality of you know i'm not
looking for that that sentence i'm
looking to really listen and understand
and get that conviction that this is
what they need now you're the the chief
technology officer about to embark on
executing
on a technology that you know is going
to be integrated in companies and and
and protect critical infrastructure what
is sort of your thinking process as
you're
designing the strategy
for no name as a company on the
technology side from day one um
my intention was to be very customer
focused so we are super super super
customer focused everything we do is
with high interaction with the customer
a lot of friction with customers we're
not just developing in a vacuum so that
was
really what led our strategy so we're
really customer focused
um we really like to say we're customer
focused we're pedaled to the metal so
we're really working as fast as we can
um
while keeping this high friction with
customers so always discussing with
customers always beating the market and
this is kind of the strategy that that
led us so if a customer is asking for
something our answer would probably
always be yes uh then we would always
execute on it as fast as we can that
that's really what led us we weren't
like um
you know we didn't come out with our set
of ideas and put it in it was really a
lot of
the short loop this short feedback loop
uh with the customers that built the
product as it is to be honest
and and do you
how do you know whether to know whether
your customers are
are enough of a of an example
that they represent you know the
industry because at the end you you
can't take feedback from 100 different
companies you want to
sort of focus and say okay this is
representative of the greater picture of
what i'm trying to build so how do you
actually know whether you're right in
that direction so we do so we do have
cyber security background right we're
not clueless like myself announced we
get cyber security in the past we had a
certain idea of what we're coming into
um so if we were clueless it would be
much more difficult but as we knew the
market we could distinguish between like
hey this is actually a big
representative and this is the noise
like because you do have to make some
distinction um
but in in them
there was a lot in there that you know
doing it just by ourselves wouldn't
wouldn't have led us that way so it was
maybe the customer feedback but also
yeah we do have to separate between the
noise and the the what's actually
important right
right so what i'm hearing here is that
there was actually a really important
piece here which is your own background
and saying you know while we so we were
we have background to be able to
distinguish the noise and to actually
come up with a lot of these conclusions
ourselves but our ability to integrate
our own background and this short
feedback loop and ask those meaningful
questions that is really the game
changer here now on on a more leadership
level internally within the organization
it's not just about the customers you're
also growing a team and and how many
engineers now are you on the r d side
so building an organization really from
from one
you two to a hundred what is sort of you
know the big milestones that you've
experienced in the growth of this
company personally as a leader
interesting question that's an
interesting question um
mime stones um there were few i think
the first big milestone was the the
initial deployment in a large you know
enterprise customer bell was a big
milestone um
you know then starting to see the sales
order really scaling up you know when
this collaboration between sales and r b
starting to tick you know starting to
work by itself we're all not you know in
the loops
that that's a very bizarre feeling it's
like it start it's like it starts
walking by itself you know this is a
weird thing because in the beginning
you're holding everything with your own
hands and suddenly you know it becomes
its own
living breathing organism that that was
another major milestone
i think the unicorn was another major
milestone for the entire company because
we worked so hard
for you know two years to get to that
point so it was almost like this huge
celebration from within you know like
wow we worked so hard i can't believe we
finally made it so that was another key
milestone those are really big
milestones that i felt as a leader other
than that you know everyone felt the
hard work it's hard work you know
working at a startup trying to build a
massive company for a massive need
like what i'd like to say is that when
we came into api security um
we were already like we had to move
really really fast if we wanted to be
relevant to that problem because that
that problem was going to explode soon
and so i told the team from day one like
hey we don't have a choice like we could
choose another market and then our work
would be easier um
but we can do it now like api security
is it is really ready for us at this
moment in time let's go for it we're
gonna bust our ass but we're gonna be in
really fast you know unicorn success
anything that comes with it and this is
really what we did we worked really
really hard but not because like we
wanted to work hard it's like the market
pushed us to do that otherwise we would
become irrelevant really
it's such a cool distinction when you're
saying that you're understanding that
you know you think guys this this is the
situation you know we we have this
understanding
the only way to really succeed in the
situation is if we go all out so we have
to make a decision whether we are now
ready to go all out on this knowing that
every hire we make is going to be
somebody who understands this notion of
where we're headed or we can choose that
if we want to have a little bit of an
easier time and we don't want to bust
our asses every weekend and 24 7 then we
can go to another market and but that
maturity of understanding of this is
what we're signing up for i think that i
think that is something that's really
really cool now on a personal level
transitioning also from engineer and
you're talking about the
this the magic of having this thing
become a breathing organism what is it
like for you as you're sort of
distancing yourself more and more from
the
core right from this from the lines of
code you're now managing close to 100
people
what what is that experience personally
it was really interesting experience
though i had to say from day one i kept
having close loop with the customers so
then
after i think half a year almost i
almost transitioned fully to being
really customer-facing so all the
important like i was the most important
technical aspect of the company like as
a cto so when you need to technically
sell something it's going to be the cto
that is there so all the initial
discussions um especially the technical
discussions with customers were led by
me and so
i found myself like almost naturally
going to the spot where i couldn't do
both i can't deal with the actual coding
and find myself in front of customers at
the same time like there wasn't enough
hours of the day
and so almost naturally i found myself
distancing there wasn't a moment in time
in which i said okay guys by buying them
you called this it was just natural that
it couldn't i just couldn't get to it um
and that's kind of how it happened i
do you miss it sorry
um
i'm trying to uh
to have at least i don't know one or two
commits in in a quarter oh but other
than that but at the end they're really
small let's say they're really they're
late but at least i see my name and uh
at least i get to see my name and then
the commit line but yeah
other than that yeah but but i didn't
miss it because there's something about
like coding like you know creating like
this passion to create
coding is really a cool way to to
achieve that but yeah i missed it but
i'm fine you know
fantastic well well cheyenne you know
you're building such an amazing
organization
and and i think it really just
represents and i
this whole theme of this conversation i
think it's the the intentionality of
understanding you know both the
intentionality of
of we're going on this mission to first
ideate and to find what we're looking
for with some of the best people in the
world with your co-founder oz with your
with with gili but then once you find it
you're again continuing with that same
intentionality intentional mindset of
saying okay now that we've we understand
what we need to do we can actually see
what is going to what it's going to take
from us and are we ready and are we
mature enough internally to go about
this exact mission that we're on and if
we succeed then in two years we'll be a
unicorn and that's exactly what happened
so shy i really want to thank you for
the the inspiration and the awesome 20
minutes i loved it i learned a lot and
best of luck with your name stay safe
and stay healthy